hey everyone welcome welcome welcome
into another edition of Market takes I
know you could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me and I
appreciate that I'm your host Dion
Robert Bowen reporter at the Wall Street
Journal this is Market takes uh you know
there's a lot going on out in the world
but we are going to tell you the three
things you need to be watching for this
week
um as you look to make sense of what's
going on in the world so big thing
obviously you've been hearing all about
it in the news uh seeing all the
headlines that's this debt ceiling
debate we're gonna break down what's
actually happening make a little sense
of all this hoopla that you're hearing
out there in the news we're going to
talk through some important housing
reports that are coming out this week
we're seeing some very significant
movement in the housing market that
think Bears watching out this week and
then we are going to get just a deluge
of U.S business conditions report from
the Federal Reserve and from others uh
this week that I think is really going
to tell us some interesting things about
the state of the economy you're going to
want to know what to watch out for there
listen let's just really quickly step
back and talk about the debt ceiling
let's separate truth from fiction and a
little bit of all the you know the blase
blah that you've been hearing about in
the headlines right now so the debt
ceiling the important thing to keep in
mind is like we don't have to argue
about this Congress doesn't have to
argue about this this is a chosen battle
the debt ceiling has been raised 78
times since 1962. uh 49 of those under
Republican presidents 29 of those under
democratic presidents it usually happens
without a lot of back and forth this
year we've got a standoff and we've got
this stand still and we are having
negotiations now we are approaching uh
June 1st that June 1st X date that
treasury secretary Janet Yellen has said
when the treasury will start to run out
of funding and have to not pay some of
its obligations uh that's happened
because we already
essentially hit the uh the the debt
ceiling number we reached the 31 31.4
trillion dollar debt limit back in late
January and the treasury Department has
already been taking Extraordinary
Measures to keep the country from not
paying some of its obligations now
important to talk about you're hearing a
lot of talk about defaulting a default
that doesn't mean the US isn't going to
pay the interest on the money that it
owes it doesn't mean there's actually
going to be a default on U.S debt
default in a way that a lot of folks
have been using that term literally just
means that some things might not get
paid some social security beneficiaries
might not get paid so Medicare
beneficiaries VA veteran assistance
things like that or Obamacare uh things
that the government is is uh on the hook
to pay for that they are mandated to pay
for they might not make a payment on the
treasury is going to prioritize paying
the debt because if the U.S doesn't pay
its debt well that could mean a debt
default which could mean a downgrade of
the U.S credit limit which could mean
that it costs significantly more for the
US to borrow which would kind of raise
the rates for borrowing across the board
in the economy that would be very bad
the treasury is going to do everything
in its power to avoid that which means
likely not paying back some of these
other things rather than defaulting or
having an actual default on the debt so
really quickly let's take a look at the
Timeline April 18th was tax day we all
know that because we had to get the
taxes in Secretary Ellen based her
elements her estimates of what the
treasury has to pay for things on uh
with the tax receipts estimates were for
that now CBO and and treasury are still
kind of counting some of these receipts
but we have an idea of how much money
came in from taxes since that April 18th
number but no one outside of the
Treasury Department actually knows how
much money because again they haven't
told us this is really just an estimate
now the Congressional budget office the
CBO has estimated and they've said that
receipts in April 2023 were 26 less than
the amount recorded in the same month
last year which means based on the
estimates they have they actually got
less in taxes than they expected and
less than last year now we've seen and
that was that was driven by a 36 percent
decline in individual income taxes cbo's
projections show a federal budget
deficit 100 billion dollars more than
estimated basically people got they got
less from taxes largely from individuals
and now they're saying okay well we've
got less money to deal with so we could
be actually closer to that sort of
default scenario or not paying back
certain or not paying for certain
obligations then that June 1st deadline
even so again when we hit June it's
likely if we don't get a deal on this
some things are not going to to be paid
you're not going to see a government
shutdown like we saw back in 2011 but
you could see some folks not getting
money that's expected some agencies not
getting money that's expected Congress
is scheduled to be out for a state work
period starting May 29th so it may be if
there's no deal today or tomorrow that
because of the way the Senate and the
house work that they may not even be
able to get even if they agree to
something something passed before that
June 1st deadline and that could mean
that some things don't get paid their
Congress is supposed to be out from May
29th to June 5th so that whole week
that's both the House and Senate are
supposed to be out they're scheduled to
be out obviously they could just not
take their state work period and stay in
congress and get a deal hammered out
June 15th is important because that's
when you get quarterly tax payments due
a lot of that money from corporations
and some money from Individual taxpayers
businesses business owners things like
that pay a quarterly so they'll get some
more money expected to get a good a good
chunk of change so the treasury has to
sort of just make things happen between
June 1st and June 15th when they'll get
some more money rolling in on June 30th
the treasury is allowed to extract about
140 billion dollars in borrowing power
from a key Federal retirement fund so
there's still money coming in there's
still going to be money coming in but
there's a lot of money going out and no
one quite knows how much it is but we do
know that we've got less than expected
from taxes and less than expected from
some of those payments that were
expected to come in really we are only
likely to reach a default as in the U.S
doesn't pay its debt obligations in
August or September because of all those
influxes and outflows of money before we
get to August or September there is
money for things to be paid but there is
not enough money and no one knows
exactly how much money there is once we
hit October an actual default of
multiple debt obligations become very
likely but again we are in in May right
now you've still got June you've still
got July you've still got August you've
still got September before it is like
likely the U.S just absolutely defaults
on its bonds however the market is
already responding and we're not seeing
much of a response in the stock market
and I'm going to show you right now
really quickly when I put this up on
your screen what we're seeing in the
market right now and what you're seeing
up there on your screen is the NASDAQ
and we have really seen the NASDAQ pick
up this chart you're seeing here is the
year to date response of the NASDAQ and
you can see we're really starting to
pick up stocks have really started to
increase and you're seeing prices rise
it shows you investors on the stock side
really not that worried but where we are
seeing some worry is in the U.S treasury
market and not on these long dated buns
you're seeing here there are some
worries about the debt ceiling deal not
coming through but if you look at the
30-year ad pretty muted you're seeing a
one basis point move on the 10-year note
the most actively traded but look down
here on this one month note boom look at
that just a huge pickup and that's
because if there's no deal the idea is
that that June uh treasury bond might
not be paid or that June Treasury Bill
may not get paid and you were seeing
folks sell that off up 15 basis points
we know when yields rise when yields
rise prices fall that means people are
selling they don't want it they're
trying to get out of that one month
treasury bill and you are seeing a
significant Market reaction I want to
show you that year to date and you
really just see it pick up here and
you've seen that since about late April
early may just a significant increase in
the value or or the uh the yield on that
one month treasury bill so that's just
illustrating how the market is
responding to this debt ceiling debate
and we are seeing a significant Market
response so let's take a step back from
this debt ceiling thing because I know
you probably heard all about that just
wanted to inject a little reality in
there the housing market reports that we
have seen last month's existing home
sales report showed the largest annual
price decline in 11 years however that
was mostly in the expensive over 500 000
houses houses below 500 000 which is
most houses on the existing home sales
Market still seeing a lot of demand
still saying prices rise I want to throw
another chart up here on your screen and
this is the new home sales report and
now what we're seeing there is an
increase in the number of new homes sold
last month we saw the March report come
in and that was the highest number of of
new homes sold in a month in about a
year going back to April of 2022. now it
looks like that September number is
close but it's not you you've seen
actually the the number of homes sold of
new homes sold and I'm sorry the number
of new homes sold in April was the
highest since April of last year so
really a big increase in new homes sold
and that chart illustrates there the
pickup we have seen in new homes sold
will that continue that's a big question
that the FED is going to want to know
that markets are going to want to know
and we're seeing an increase in Supply
but we're not seeing prices falling and
in fact new home sales the median price
was almost 450 000 up from 438 thousand
dollars last month so this week's new
home sales report out on Tuesday we'll
be very watched and very well followed
you want to check that out we also get
the pending home sales report on
Thursday that's going to be the latest
detail on that
um one chart I want to throw up here on
your screen as well is this chart
showing mortgage rates and I want you to
contrast what we've seen over the past
uh over the course of this year with
mortgage rates which have really risen a
little bit gone down a little bit but
they're largely right where they were at
the beginning of the year to that chart
you saw with new home sales new home
sales have picked up significantly even
though mortgage rates have not declined
even though they're still around that
that high level that we saw in November
of last year and this chart just
illustrates that even though mortgage
rates have not declined very simply we
have seen a defined and clear pickup in
new home sales that really just showing
you that the housing market could be
coming back and that'll be important for
the Federal Reserve last thing we want
to talk about business conditions
reports we get a number of reports out
this week we've already got the U.S
services and Manufacturing reports those
come about in Tuesday those are for May
and that's the latest update on business
conditions in the US you'll want to
watch those because conditions have been
deteriorating through a lot of surveys
we get the Richmond fed survey on
Tuesday we get minutes from the federal
reserve's last policy meeting on
Wednesday that's going to tell us a lot
and that could be Market moving we'll
also get the Chicago fed National
activity index on Thursday the Kansas
City fed survey on Thursday and the
advanced economic indicators report on
Friday that's going to tell us a lot
about the state of the economy and
you'll want to watch that listen that's
going to do it for us here on Market
takes I'm your host Dion rabone reporter
at the Wall Street Journal thank you so
much for being with us and I hope you'll
be with us again next time